well tonight is officially like a
precursor to award season so kickoff is
the kickoff it's officially the kickoff
wrestlers has been getting a lot of a
successful attention so how are you
preparing for the next few months for
this award show marathon you know I'm
just taking it one day at a time
do it taking it in stride I'm super
excited for the movie for everyone
involved with the movie and just gonna
try to enjoy every minute stay present
yes and you definitely have to stay
present because you have a number of
jobs that you're juggling up until award
season I mean yes it's cooking off today
but I'm not mistaken you've got maybe a
little thing called s and L coming up
this Saturday night now this this week I
thought you were gonna say the Super
Bowl but yeah we got a little bit of
time to wear this today yeah yeah not me
I don't have that much time now you're
already a deep inner Arizona where we're
starting we're starting together so how
are you mapping things out or what is
the process of mapping out a show like
the Super Bowl I don't have to remind
you the millions of eyes that have in a
minute it's just about like for me I'm
obviously gonna try to put together the
best show that I can but also it's about
having fun you know just being up there
and enjoy again staying present in the
moment and enjoying all of the wonderful
things that are happening right now this
I mean that's such an achievement though
so what are some elements that you're
really hoping to put into your Super
Bowl performance I wouldn't give away
any of those secrets right now oh come
on Jay
and we still have to develop it a little
bit more yeah all right well we're doing
a lotta Super Bowl shoots in the coming
week so let us know if we can get in on
anything
and obviously with SNL is maybe Alex is
gonna make a little cameo of some oh
there was no talk about no no not yet
I'm gonna be the hustler girls like make
an appearance as AV I don't know maybe
no nothing isn't talked to all right
there's nothing to give you rights all
right
[Music]